simple life that's crazy 20 year
anniversary is coming up 20 year
anniversary what do you remember from
that you and Nicole yeah yes look at
your little baby you're little baby
thank you Nicole and I just the most
amazing memories we're actually at my
house like last month watching some
episodes together and just is that hard
do you watch like this no we love it we
just laugh so hard that show is just so
hilarious it was so much fun I think
that my favorite was the Walmart episode
yes I was like oh my God grew up in a
Walmart we're so
different I am the people of Walmart uh
you know that thing you see online like
totally me I know I love how I said
what's Walmart do they sell Walls there
and now we're selling Paris Hilton
cookware I know well you know what it is
it's a great it's hard to get your stuff
in Walmart people don't realize that
it's hard to get your stuff in like
Walmart or Target like those are like
places those are hard places to get like
you're seven to SOG killing it selling
out everywhere so it's amazing
I love it awesome well so you recently
posted this um old picture and this was
you and Britney y'all were young um so
younger I should say but Britney
actually just released a memoir as well
and she said something really cool so
I'm get to tell every ready so it says
one of the people who was kindest to me
when I really needed kindness was Paris
Hilton like that's you know I don't feel
like good news gets spread often it's
always like this person did this to me
this person it's always bad I thought it
was really cool to like read something
kind about someone and like lift that up
did you feel good about yeah I was
crying when I read that I thought that
was just that really touched me she's
just so strong I love her so much and
I'm just so proud of her for speaking
her truth and writing this whole book
and yeah that quote just meant a lot to
me when I read it yeah and you both were
very young in this industry and like
growing up that can't be easy so well
you know how it is yeah I I feel like
there has to be purpose in things that
happen to us the good and the bad and I
love that you're a really big advocate
for like treble teen industry like
anything going on in that area because
you had struggled that's really cool so
that's important to you to keep up yes
and I'm just so proud of all the impact
that I've made with telling my story
I've now changed laws in 10 states and
going back and forth to Washington DC
and we're pushing for federal
legislation and we've made it bipartisan
we have both sides that are supporting
this so congratulations that never
happens yeah really proud that's really
cool like cuz I think that people look
at you like from afar and maybe don't
know like your life they will with the
Memoir but like I don't think they know
that and so it's kind of cool for people
that are struggling to go okay I can do
this like she did this I think that's
really important you yeah and changing
laws you're doing everything
[Music]
[Applause]
okay thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home